okay so what exactly is let's start at
the beginning what exactly is in
this coveted relief bill according to
emily zenati writing for the daily well
daily wire congress is set to pass two
major spending bills on monday a nearly
1 trillion
coronavirus relief bill and a 1.4
trillion omnibus bill in a
record-setting vote that will fund
hundreds of government programs and
according to lawmakers assist individual
americans struggling to make ends meet
because of kova 19
related restrictions the bill does in
fact contain some help for those facing
economic struggles
in addition to providing a second round
of direct stimulus checks to individual
taxpayers this time 600 bucks the bill
extends federal supplemental
unemployment benefits right that is the
really big check it's not the 600
check it is the extension of federal
supplemental unemployment benefits the
jobless as well as gig employees
experiencing a slowdown in business
can now get an extra 300 bucks per week
through march through mid-march so if
you are on
unemployment insurance you're really
talking about like an 1800
check every month you're not talking
about 600 i'm at 1800
and that is on top of whatever state aid
you are getting
as well the coronavirus relief package
expands paycheck protection as well
opening up
248 billion dollars in funding for loans
to struggling businesses
even as evidence emerges that millions
from the first round of ppp loans went
to connected
corporations this is of course the great
risk of all of these bills
as they turn into cronyism and they're
packed jam-packed with like a bunch of
crap that doesn't mean anything
this time around the covet 19 bill
contains special grants for specific
industries
20 billion for businesses in low-income
communities 15 billion dollars for
struggling live venues
movie theaters and museums i'm not sure
it is worthwhile bailing out movie
theaters to be perfectly frank with you
and this comes as from somebody who
loves movie theaters i love movie
theaters my wife and i
used to go on lots of dates to movie
theaters before the covet shutdown
happened i love seeing movies in the
theater
i think it's a great tragedy that this
may be a communal experience that goes
the way the dodo bird
but i don't know why we're spending 15
billion to bail out movie theaters
not given the fact that you've got
places like hbo max that have already
explained that they are going to
simultaneously release things in
theaters and at home which means that
people are just not going to go to
theaters i think that
movie theaters are going to be the last
thing to come back and it's going to
become more of a specialty thing i don't
think you're going to see movie theaters
on you know every other corner the way
that you used to there are a number of
breaks for businesses according to emily
some of which haven't gone over well
on social media the relief bill includes
a two-year tax break for business meals
this is a priority for president trump
apparently and rolls over a variety of
temporary tax breaks known as extenders
for some for multiple years
the business meal deduction has been
labeled the three martini lunch
deduction that very few people aside
from key democratic legislators
in major cities are having many dining
luncheons as emily zanotti suggest
the bill also helps renters there's a 25
billion assistance
program and a continued eviction
moratorium under the coven 19 relief
deal 13 billion
will go to food benefits 15 billion to a
program for direct payments to farmers
to assist in keeping american food
production
afloat well i wasn't aware that we had
like a problem in keeping american food
production afloat considering that
demand
is still kind of the same in the
american food markets it's just going
through different channels just not
going through restaurants there are big
handouts in the bill
airlines get 15 billion again i'm not
sure that that is worthwhile i'm not
sure the taxpayer should be paying out
airlines who've experienced
this shock and setback you don't want
them going bankrupt you want them still
existing obviously
but it seems to me that airlines it's
going to be a while before people are
traveling in quite the way that
they used to people are not going to
travel casually quite as easily for
probably a couple of years particularly
if you're elderly
airports are gonna get two billion
dollars amtrak is gonna get a billion
dollars so
i guess that leaves joe biden and pete
booty just particularly happy very very
romantic amtrak
higher education is gonna get 82 billion
dollars
higher education should receive zero
dollars okay they should not receive 82
billion
higher education is wildly overpriced
has been pushed up
in the marketplace by federal loans in
the first place there's a good case to
be made that
huge swaths of higher education should
be left on the cutting room floor
including
many of the what we would call north
campus majors at ucla the liberal arts
majors should be left on the cutting
room floor
i do not know why we are dumping out 82
billion dollars to
higher education particularly at a time
when you are looking at places like
harvard that have billion dollar
endowments that makes no sense to me the
u.s postal service
also wins big congress used the bill to
forgive a 10 billion
loan to the u.s postal service a loan
they gave to the service in an earlier
coronavirus relief bill
usps has no hope of ever paying back
states will get 20 billion dollars to
help purchase vaccines and distribute
them they also get 20 billion to help
with expanding kova 19 testing
they don't get a bailout for the
economic damage they've incurred during
the extended virus lockdown
democrats pushed for that republicans
said no on the other hand republicans
were pushing
for a limit to legal liability for
corporations
based on covid right if they said you
need to come to work if you're not sick
and then people came to work and they
were sick
people were going to sue these
corporations apparently they still can
theoretically
there are further expenditures that are
now coming to light apparently the final
draft of the bill contains a number of
handouts for congress
including a provision paying for the
additional pandemic expenditures
incurred by the congressional daycare
center ooh
sounds great and 5 million bucks to
protect members from the coronavirus by
expanding testing and increasing the
budget
of the congressional physician also the
washington d.c government
got 38 million in reimbursements for its
work controlling protests and providing
security
i just why did they do a good job with
that did i miss the part where the
washington dc
government did a fantastic job
controlling protests and providing
security
when people were literally running
through downtown washington you see just
breaking
store windows that that seems like a
waste of money
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content